wanted to celebrate another example of
the success of the president's
industrial policy with governor roy
cooper announcing the electric vehicle
maker vinfast is investing four billion
dollars to build electric vehicle and
batteries in north carolina
that's an investment that will create
more than 7 000 jobs on top of the 423
000 manufacturing jobs created on the
president's watch in his first year in
office the most in a single year since
the early 1990s
we're building on that momentum with the
bipartisan infrastructure law which is
making historic investments in our roads
bridges airports and more
along with things like ev charging
stations that are critical for america
to own emerging industries
and we have a chance to redouble that
progress with the bipartisan innovation
act which cleared through the senate
last night with a massive bipartisan
majority this is legislation that will
boost manufacturing strengthen our
supply chains lower prices and boost our
economic and national security by making
more critical components like
semiconductors right here in america
we look forward to the house of
representatives moving quickly to start
the formal conference on that bill so we
can get this to the president's desk as
soon as possible
and with that i'm happy to take your
questions darlene why don't you kick us
off thanks peter welcome thank you um i
wanted to follow up with one question on
the readout from the president's call
earlier today with the european leaders
can you say if they spent
any time at all talking about his
comment that putin cannot remain in
power or should not remain in power they
did not i spoke with the president about
this earlier they did not uh they were
incredibly aligned however and spoke to
some of the key issues uh that we are
focused on here including supply to
supplying weapons to ukraine including
uh increasing costs on russia continuing
to increase sanctions uh supporting
stable energy markets and of course the
state of diplomatic negotiations and
obviously the conversation today came on
the heels of the president's successful
trip to europe last week
in which uh he stood with some of our
european allies and announced uh efforts
to redouble nato uh forces on the
eastern flank to announce an additional
one billion dollars in humanitarian aid
to ukraine uh and to sh and to continue
to show uh incredible unity with our
european partners and allies as we uh
tackle this crisis in russia second
question is there any uh comment or
reaction to the fda approving a fort
booster shot for people over 50.
so uh this is a good thing uh and it is
a straightforward thing uh the cdc and
the fda are now uh allowing uh and will
make available uh booster shots a fourth
shot for uh people over 50 for the and
for the immuno-compromised
uh this is we have plenty of supply
to ensure that those populations can
receive these shots
but what i would say is that
if it at some point it becomes
recommended that
the full uh the full population
get uh requires a fourth shot we're
going to need additional funding we're
going to need the additional funding
we've requested of congress to be able
to provide uh to provide those shots for
the for the broader population but we do
have the supply uh and people will be
able to go uh people in those
populations over uh 50 and up uh will be
able to go and and get those shots
um
first i want to ask about the turrets
that are happening uh talks that are
happening underway in turkey between the
russians and the ukrainians what is the
white house's visibility into those
discussions and have us officials have
seen abby any evidence uh to back up
russia's claims that they're pulling
some of their forces back from keep up
so the president said he wanted to see
what the russians actually did versus
what they said yeah
so we are in close contact with
ukrainians and are supportive of their
efforts to engage in diplomacy and to
try to reach a ceasefire we are prepared
to be helpful however we can and are
focused on
putting ukraine in the strongest
possible position both on the
battlefield and at the negotiating table
we obviously continue to provide
security assistance to provide weapons
to ensure that that they are able to
push back on russian aggression
and we continue to increase pressure on
putin and on russia by imposing severe
costs
in partnership with our allies and
partners so we defer to the ukrainians
to discuss the specifics of the
negotiations but we are of course
committed to a ukraine that is uh that
is sovereign independent and secure and
we are in constant conversation with the
ukrainian government and our allies and
partners but as always we keep those
conversations private to your second
question about kiev obviously and what
we heard from the russians today you
obviously heard the president address
this and say that we'll need to watch
and see
if their actions meet their words but i
think we should be clear-eyed about the
reality of what's happening on the
ground and no one should be fooled by
russia's announcements we believe any
movement of forces from around heave is
a redeployment and not a withdrawal and
the world should be prepared for a major
offensive against other areas of ukraine
everyone
should expect that we're going to
continue to see attacks across ukraine
obviously a key message uh that the
president delivered on his trip to your
in his trip to europe last week uh was
that we are in for a long slog that our
allies and partners need to remain uh
that our resolve needs to remain strong
and that we need to continue to execute
on the strategy of uh of inflicting
significant costs in the russian economy
uh and again strengthening ukraine on
the battlefield and at the negotiating
table on the subject of the president's
remarks in poland about president putin
obviously yesterday he tried to suggest
that there was a distinction between his
personal views of what he thought was a
moral outrage versus an official
policy position on the part of the
united states but you know full well
something that candidate joe biden said
virtually every day on the campaign
trail which is that the words of a
president matter that they can as he
often put it lead a country into war
is he not living up to he'll hit the
standard that he said himself during the
campaign absolutely not i think the
words of the president here were
incredibly powerful he spoke personally
about the moral outrage that he felt
which is shared by people all across the
world it does not mean he is
articulating a change in policy it does
not mean he's laying out
a change in u.s policy he met
with refugees as again many of you were
on that trip and saw and saw that
firsthand some of the pain that vladimir
putin has inflicted on on people who are
fleeing their homes and who are seeing
their country war-torn so this was an
incredibly personal uh powerful
statement of moral outrage
it was not an articulation of a new u.s
policy and i think both of those things
can be and are true you spend some time
with the president last question
is he frustrated or does he regret that
those words at the very end of the
speech overshadowed a larger message
which obviously he put a lot of thought
into in the days
absolutely not he spoke from the heart
he as he always does as you know very
well from having covered him for a long
time as many of you do and as the
american people know he speaks from the
heart he says what he feels and uh no he
absolutely does not regret that in any
way justin sings hey kate um
following on darling's question will the
president vice president be receiving
fourth booster shots in diabetes
timeline on that so i can speak uh to
the president who will
make this decision in consultation with
his doctor obviously if his doctor
recommends that he receive a fourth
booster then he would but he'll make
that decision in consultation with his
doctor i will check on the vice
president i don't know
earlier you were talking about the call
and supporting stable energy markets
during the president's trip last week
there seemed to be momentum behind the
idea of a coordinated
strategic petroleum reserve release and
so i'm wondering if you can provide any
update on
whether that topic came up in the
conversation today or a time frame or
outlook for that i can only say that
they spoke to the stability of energy
markets writ large and the need to keep
them stable i don't have any specifics
to preview in terms of any coming
announcements what i would say more
broadly of course is that obviously
president biden is very focused on
ensuring that we minimize uh
fluctuations as much as possible at the
gas the gas pump
and prices in general
for american families he is doing
everything he can to combat putin's
price hike here at home that's why they
we did the initial coordinated release
of 60 million barrels from the strategic
petroleum reserve um and he will
continue to focus on this but i don't
have any specific preview that i can
give you at this time
our friends over the journal yesterday
reported that members of the ukrainian
um peace negotiation team
exhibited signs of natural poisoning i'm
wondering if that was something
the u.s has been aware of tracking and
if you sort of describe responsibility
to the russians so we are certainly
aware um we are obviously alarmed by
these reports especially given the fact
that this is something that historically
has been in russia's playbook
but i do not have any uh confirmation uh
at this time except to say that we are
aware
thanks kate you just said and the
pentagon is also saying the same thing
that any movement of forces in ukraine
of russian forces is not a withdrawal or
repositioning is that based on
intelligence or what is what is that
based on that is based on the fact that
uh we need to see what the russians
actually do before uh we trust solely
what they've said we saw from the outset
that they made an aggressive push toward
keeve at the beginning of this conflict
and we have no reason to believe that
they have adjusted uh that they have
adjusted that strategy
obviously
we continue to do everything we can to
impose costs for this decision we will
continue to execute on our strategy
but as you heard the president say
we are not going to take their word for
it we're going to wait to see what their
actions look like and the british prime
minister said today that they won't
accept anything less than a full
withdrawal of all russian forces from
ukrainian territory does president biden
share that view that reduced military
activity is not enough
well we are
going to allow the the ukrainians to to
execute on these negotiations it's not
our role to begin the negotiation again
our role is to strengthen ukraine on the
battlefield to try to strengthen ukraine
at the negotiating table by implying
these sanctions and costs to russia but
um i'm not going to uh to prejudge or
predetermine an outcome for that
conversation and last question for you
jared kushner is set to testify before
the january 6 committee on thursday
virtually has the white house had any
communication with him about whether or
not you're going to waive any executive
privilege claims that he could make
so obviously the president has spoken uh
to the fact that january 6 was one of
the darkest days in our country's
history and that we must have a full
accounting of what happened to ensure
that it never occurs again and he's been
quite clear that they posed a unique
threat to our democracy and that the
constitutional protections of executive
privilege should not be used to shield
from congress or the public information
about an attack on the constitution
itself and so as a result the white
house has decided not to assert
executive privilege over the testimony
of jared kushner and ivanka trump and
have you communicated that to jared
kushner's team or is this
i won't i won't speak i won't speak to
uh private communication between our
attorneys and his
thank you kate um
just sort of with russia redeploying to
focus on on eastern ukraine what is your
view on whether russia should be allowed
to retain control of the dark last
region as you're aware they have you
know um just today said that you know
that is what that is what their demand
is and i'm wondering if the us has a
formalized position on that
so again i am not going to uh pre-judge
where these negotiations ultimately net
out we are doing everything we can to
provide weapons to the ukrainian people
so that they can turn back russian
aggression and we're doing everything we
can to impose severe costs uh on russia
and on the russian economy i am not
going to prejudge the ultimate uh
outcome certainly not uh from standing
here at this podium and uh just a quick
question um on um the deputy treasury
secretary he spoke a little while
earlier and said there are more
sanctions coming this time they'll be
focused on russian supply chains are
there any more details that you can
potentially share with us and what that
looks like and when that will happen so
i don't have additional specifics that i
can provide uh in terms of announcements
coming at this time except to say more
broadly um you know that certainly we
have hit in console in concert with our
allies and partners we've hit very hard
at the things that putin cares about the
most we degrading his military access to
cutting-edge technology chipping away at
his chokehold on energy an ability to
project power and influence and of
course we will continue to intensify and
we're not going to run out of options
anytime soon
there are plenty of things that we can
do including broadening sanctions to new
targets deepening the severity of
sanctions that are existing
so i don't have any specifics to
announce at this time uh except to say
that there are certainly other options
should we decide to move forward with
them that quickly from let me ask you
about just follow up on the january 6th
committee
liberals have suggested that they're
disappointed with the way that the
justice department under attorney
general garland has approached the
former president
how does the president feel about this
question
the president has the utmost respect for
the independence of the department of
justice and does not have any comment on
that and so the sense here is that the
president has
confidence in the way the justice
department has been handling all of
these cases
again i'm not going to speak to specific
handling of cases obviously the
president has full faith in attorney
general garland to run his department
the way he sees fit
hey on the president and the coronavirus
you've said there'll be consultations
about a fourth shot i wonder if the
president's reached recent travel
overseas with several members of the
white house staff um coming down with
coronavirus are there any additional
measures or medication anything else
that's being done to sort of protect the
president's health and welfare
so you know let me talk a little bit
about uh some of the uh procedures and
give you an overview of our our policy
here so
the white house takes incredibly strong
precautions in alignment and sometimes
as you all know beyond cdc guidance to
ensure that we're keeping a safe
workplace especially for the president
of the united states
so all uh eop executive office of the
president employees who surround the
president
are tested on a regular cadence here on
campus to screen for covid that is a
step beyond cdc guidance to help lower
the risk of covid on campus we do
regular uh regular screening testing
the president's doctor determines if
additional testing is needed in any
given week
in light of various considerations so
more specifically to your question
because of his travel this week he will
test in addition to his regular testing
cadence
um everyone going into a meeting with
one of the four principals is required
to test ahead of time and that's how we
know
about some of these positive cases in
the first place
so for those employees who test positive
they're required to isolate in alignment
with cdc guidance and must test negative
before turning to returning to work
which uh is also a step beyond cdc
guidance so we take every uh every
measure here to ensure that we are
protecting
the four principles and also protecting
our staff
and our workforce but because of his
travel he will do some additional
testing in addition to his regular
cadence to follow up i want to make sure
i'm clear what about any medications is
he taking any additional medications or
any other treatments or anything like
that i understand about the testing and
about we all get tested when we get near
the president um but is there anything
else that's not something that i'm not
going to get into private medical
information from here except to say that
uh the president will receive additional
testing as part of his cadence uh to
ensure uh that uh that kovid that he
doesn't have coven
thank you um just to follow up on that
when was he last tested and i guess we
presume he was negative because he's
with the prime minister
uh yes you know i will get you the date
i want to say um
i actually want to say it was yesterday
but but because i think we announced it
publicly yesterday so i believe his last
test was yesterday and uh yes it was
negative he said yesterday that he would
be willing to
meet with president putin again or talk
to him i'm wondering what specific
circumstances need to be met for such a
meeting to take place well i think he
articulated uh pretty clearly that it
would depend on what president putin
wanted to talk about i'm not going to
set uh i'm not going to set
preconditions for a conversation between
president biden and president putin
except to say that we have been very
clear and president biden has been very
clear that there needs to be uh tangible
de-escalation uh from russia and a clear
genuine commitment to diplomacy uh
before the president would have that
kind of conversation yeah and on the
covet funding um do you have any update
i i know you say you need the money but
do you have any update on the
negotiations it seems like there are
serious conversations happening up on
the hill um do you have any sense of
when or how this might be resolved are
you more optimistic than you were last
week for instance well we're continuing
to push i mean this this funding is
important it's going to be important to
ensure that we are uh well-funded in the
event that another variant comes along
or in the event that we see another wave
that we need to be prepared for so
you know we view this funding as really
critical
we've been working with congress as you
know well for the last several months
they know that we need the funding to
stay ahead of the virus
they're also aware of some of the
specific details like for example that
already the uninsured fund has stopped
except accepting claims uh and we've
been forced to cut monoclonal supply to
states by a third this week so there are
real tangible impacts um to not having
this funding
i think there is widespread agreement
that funding for vaccines tests and
treatments is urgent and critical
and we need to see this urgency from
congress and we're going to continue to
push
thanks uh ukraine is now asking for
security guarantees as part of these
negotiations what kinds of guarantees is
the us willing to provide to ensure
ukraine sovereignty
so uh these are not uh specifics that
i'm prepared to be able to announce from
from this podium obviously we are
working uh very closely uh with ukraine
on a wide array of options things to
help
ensure we are ensure their sovereignty
and ensure their security now some of
that is providing uh the weapons that
we're providing some of that is
continuing to push on sanctions and
costs on russia um but i don't have any
specifics to to preview for you on any
on any discussions about security
guarantees and on the concern over
chemical weapons you know with russia
now seeming to make some concessions and
at least promising to reduce military
activity are you still as concerned that
russia could use chemical weapons or is
that threat seen as diminishing we
continue to prepare for every
contingency we obviously take seriously
a wide array of potential options there
has been uh reporting um uh in the
public uh in the public sphere over the
last weeks about uh all the work that
our teams are doing to prepare for
eventuality so i'm not gonna rate the
likelihood
of of one or another outcome except to
say that our teams are preparing for um
for all eventualities and you know the
president has been very clear that um
you know we will
respond with severe consequences as we
have responded with severe consequences
to every action russia has taken up
until this point a similar question with
regards to china do you see russia's
promise to to somehow pull back some of
its forces as a sign that china is not
willing to or will not be assisting them
so i don't have any uh updated guidance
beyond what you all heard from jake for
example last week about us uh not having
seen any evidence of china uh uh
providing any sort of military
assistance to russia
thank you kate um there are reports that
the administration is going to require
cobit vaccines for undocumented migrants
of the southwest border
just as title 42 is expected to end and
right after the fourth shot got fda
approval
you just highlighted the impacts of not
having enough covert funding when it
comes to paying for shots for the
uninsured and sending shipments of
treatments to states so why would the
administration give out free vaccines to
undocumented migrants but not to for
instance uninsured americans well to be
clear we have the supply that we need uh
in this moment to vaccinate uh americans
here in this country i don't want to
conflate those two things because i
think that's not that's not an accurate
representation
of what i said we have we have the
supply that we need to vaccinate
americans what we are asking for is
funding to prepare for future
eventualities and to ensure that we have
what we need as we move forward now on
your question about the border this is
nothing new the effort to vaccinate
migrants in our care and custody has
been ongoing for months ice has been
providing vaccines to migrants since the
summer of 2021 and we're always
assessing the situation and addressing
protocols based on
changing cdc guidance
you know but in order to ensure the
safety of border communities and the
workforce and the migrants themselves
dhs is now requiring age-appropriate
vaccinations for non-citizens who are
taken into border patrol custody but
again this is consistent with overall
cdc guidance for those entering the
country uh be it by air or land and we
know that vaccinating people
is the best way to protect from the
virus and to protect against the spread
of the virus
the new york times story framed it as
something that was about to get underway
in certain sectors of the southwest
border um is this some this requirement
for a vaccine is is that accurate is
that something that is going to take
place because the reason i ask is if
you're talking about future supply and
this is a future effort how are those
two things not
sort of in conflict well as i said it's
it is actually nothing new i mean we
have been vaccinating migrants in our
care and custody for many many months so
ice as i said has been providing
vaccines to migrants since the summer of
2021. uh so this is not anything new as
we know that this is again the best way
to protect people from the virus and to
prevent the spread of the viruses to
ensure that they're vaccinated title 42
is about to end then i have no
announcement that i can make on title
42. on ukraine um
yesterday did the president accidentally
reveal a previously unknown
effort for the the u.s to be training
ukrainian forces in poland during his
answer in the press conference uh no the
troops that he met with uh in poland
routinely interact with ukrainians
that is something that's known many of
you were again on the trip with us
that is something that's known that is
in no way revealing compromised
information
that being said um there's nothing
further that i have to say on that
beyond what the president said yesterday
just to follow up i know you said just
now you don't have any news on title 42
which expires on friday um
at least the current
uh use of it um when you were when we
were in europe the president announced
that he's admitting 100 000 ukrainian
asylum seekers
um
they are exempt from title 42.
why
so obviously we are looking at uh
an extreme crisis uh in in ukraine i
think it's um
uh it is it is easy to look at the
incredible volume of displacement and
the duress that people are under in
ukraine and understand that we need to
make uh we need to make efforts to
ensure that we are uh moving to get them
to places that are safe um what i can
say more broadly um about our efforts to
um
to to bring a hundred thousand uh
ukrainian
uh refugees into the country um is that
you know
we anticipate that most of these uh
refugees will want to stay closer to
home will want to stay in europe
but we are making every uh
we are putting forward this effort um to
ensure that we're able to to accommodate
a hundred thousand obviously on the
specifics of that i have to refer you to
the state department on the specific
workings
but it is important as you heard the
president say when we were overseas uh
it's important for
for the united states to do its part and
for those countries bordering ukraine to
not be the only ones to shoulder the
burden you heard him talk about that uh
while we were on the ground in warsaw
so the policy decision has been made
that the war in ukraine and the
displacement of those people
is more urgent to the united states than
the displacement of millions of people
due to earthquakes hurricanes and
political strife in this atmosphere i i
think that's a little bit putting words
in my mouth my point was only that were
that that's
on this side of the world that's a
little bit putting words in my mouth all
i'm saying is that we have put forward
uh a process to allow 100 to bring 100
000 uh ukrainian refugees into the
country given the uh incredible duress
and the crisis uh that they're facing in
their homeland two other quick
follow-ups you said to cleve on the
question of any medications the
president may be taking because of code
but that's private medical information
is that to say that if he is taking
something currently it will be revealed
in his next medical report that we get
at some point that's a lexus and
prescorer and diminished have been
revealed in the last one that's simply
to say that i don't have anything in
this moment to provide at this at the
podium that's uh medical information if
there is a moment in which it needs to
be disclosed it would obviously be
disclosed as you know uh we put out an
incredibly fulsome uh physical report uh
uh on the president's health every year
so that's simply to say i don't have
anything to disclose from this podium at
this time and then on the trump uh
logs that appear to have hours of
information missing
um has the january 6 committee asked
this white house to try to find that
information or implore the archives to
dig deeper for them has the white house
counsel's office attempted to help
reconstruct that record at all i would
refer you to uh to the archives on that
i don't have any additional information
from the council's office at this time
okay
thank you thank you kate uh two two ones
on ukraine
again um so the sanctions are obviously
the stick
is a is there some thinking already
about what carrot could be you know
essentially
is there gonna be some sort of schedule
laid out like you know you do this this
comes off
you know a root map i suppose what it's
called
well i don't know that uh russian
activity at this time uh necessarily
merits a carrot we have been very
focused on the stick um again i am not
going to pre-judge or
or lay down any contours of any ultimate
negotiation that is not our role again
our role is to strengthen ukraine on the
battlefield strengthen uh ukraine at the
negotiating table i'm not going to
prejudge uh any of the uh what
ultimately those diplomatic solutions
may or may not look like okay i'm just
finding off on your previous answer
about the uh
troops in poland
um jen did say clearly last week there
are no u.s training programs for
ukrainians outside of ukraine obviously
not in ukraine but nowhere else either i
actually asked a question that's what
she said no
um so the president yesterday and i've
got his quote it was very clear he said
but he was when he had this chat with
the us troops he said it was all about
them helping to train the ukrainian
troops that are in poland so are they
training them in poland or they're not
training well as i said there is regular
interaction between ukrainian soldiers
uh in poland and the u.s troops that the
president saw on the trip there's
nothing no further detail that i can add
on that uh except to say that there is
regular interaction as you saw we were
there near the border
and there's regular interaction between
those troops that he saw in ukrainians
just to follow up on uh russian
ibrahimovic who was photographed today
during the peace talks does the u.s have
a clear idea what his role is during
these talks
uh i don't have more to say uh from this
podium about his role um uh you know
that is something that um
i i'm simply not equipped to speak to uh
in this moment except to say again of
course that we are um we are looking at
uh the allegations uh into potential
harm to him uh and tracking very closely
and just to follow up on the refugees
the 100 000 announcement from last week
um we were told that there would be a
range of legal pathways for them and
that would be announced is that
something that you guys are still
working on or are we can we expect you
know details about that program
it is um and you know to meet the
commitment that the president laid out
to welcome a hundred thousand ukrainian
refugees we're considering the full
range of legal pathways to the united
states so that includes the u.s refugee
admissions program that includes parole
that includes immigrant and
non-immigrant visas so we are continuing
to work through those options
and again ultimately i would refer you
to the state department for additional
detail on how that will how that will
work can i actually can i ask you a
follow-up question on refugees
so
many people have been advocating that
what you are doing for ukrainian right
now is what you should also do for
ethiopia as you know tens of thousands
of ethiopians have been killed millions
have been displaced why not do the same
thing that you do to
europeans to africa to ethiopia and then
to
cameroonian and then one second question
i want to talk about will smith and
chris rob you know it's the biggest
story right now you saw the level of
violence that was unleashed on on police
drugs is that something that the white
house condoned the type that type of
violence do you condemn it and do you do
anything to support committee and who
are being attacked and other artists
thank you so i don't have any official
comment from the white house on the
altercation i know the president uh was
not able to watch the oscars uh didn't
see it so i don't have anything i don't
have any official comment uh from him or
from the white house on this
thank you
you're right i don't have any additional
detail uh on any plans there uh
obviously uh you know as we are focused
on uh working to bring uh to welcome 100
000 ukrainian refugees here that does
not uh uh
you know that does not eliminate work
that's being done uh in other areas i
don't have any specifics uh to announce
from this podium at this time on any
plans but if you condemn the violence at
the oscar is it is that something that
you condemn or you can't i don't i don't
have a white house comment on that
the washington uh the washington post
reports that anita done was here at the
white house on a special one-week
assignment last month um i'm wondering
if you tell us a little bit more about
you know what was so important for her
to be brought in on a one-week
assignment like that and then do any
other staffers
or former staffers invite in world enjoy
that sort of drop-in
opportunity and finally
is it true that dunn avoided any ethics
rules that would restrict former white
house officials from lobbying one year
after
leaving the post
so
what i would say to that is anita is an
incredibly trusted advisor who has known
the president for a long time and she
did recently uh come back to the white
house temporarily to bring her expertise
and add capacity at a key time for the
white house
um she
came to to fill in for a staffer who
needed to be out for personal reasons uh
she did this as an sge as you know a
special government employee uh which is
a temporary uh short-term um assignment
uh and classification for uh for
employees who come to work for the white
house in a temporary um
in a temporary manner
um it's a designation that past
administrations have used for the same
purpose and anita is not the only person
to have served in this administration as
an sge
anita and other sges receive rigorous
counseling on their ethics obligations
as an sge including avoiding any
potential conflicts of interest
and anita of course has always held
herself to the highest standards
consistent with this administration's
commitment to ethics abiding by all
federal ethics laws and policies
applicable to sgs and then one more
45 minutes after the president's remarks
are wrapped in warsaw on saturday that
was when a statement landed in
everyone's inboxes from an unnamed white
house official saying that no the
administration did not in fact
change its policy with regards to russia
i'm wondering if you can tell us
anything about what happened in the
interim um in that 45 minutes did the
president himself uh conclude that
perhaps there needed to be some
further clarification
or did white house advisors come to him
and say perhaps you should revisit your
recent remarks why was that statement
issued
well i can tell you from working for
president biden for seven years that
only president biden decides what
president biden is going to say so uh
the
the statement was simply a confirmation
of what the president what you then
heard from the president himself
yesterday uh that that statement did not
represent uh a policy change official
policy change on behalf of the united
states
i mean did that come from the president
that particular statement he's
referencing did that come from him to
you all or did you all go to him and say
we have to put this out i'm not going to
get in into any further back and forth
except to say that i have worked for him
for a long time and only he determines
what he's going to follow
um have you all considered when i spoke
with authorities in in ukraine they were
saying the no uh no fly zone or the cap
clycat that they'd like over their
country would be they could sustain that
with lend lease of aircraft and
volunteer pilots has that been
approached as the administration
considered that would they consider or
would they consider that well i think
the president has been uh explicitly
clear uh that he does not intend to
engage
u.s troops in any way in direct conflict
with the russian military
and so i'm sorry this wouldn't be troops
they're talking about land lease for the
aircraft and they would supply the
pilots
there are so i guess a couple of things
one is the assessment of our military uh
is that the
anti-air anti-tank the
munitions that we're providing to the
ukrainians are the most effective things
that they can have on the battlefield
that's the assessment of our military
commanders
and and of course something that the
president factors significantly into his
decision-making the second thing i would
say is that again he has been very clear
that he is not interested in uh engaging
uh the u.s military in direct conflict
uh with russia and there are logistics
you know for example on the question of
the migs there are significant
logistical challenges
that may raise those issues so
uh as to whether there's a specific
discussion about lynn lease i don't have
any uh further detail that i can provide
on that except to just lay out those
kind of two key points that have really
been driving uh the president's thinking
and decision making on this as far as
the uh assessment of the uh sanctions
when they first went in president said
hey give us a month and then we'll look
at them been a month you happy or what
would you like to change or are you
satisfied with where they're going with
regard to the sanctions that have been
applied to russia yes uh i think you've
seen us continue to escalate uh over the
course of the last uh since the invasion
began on the 24th of february um you've
seen
unprecedented costs inflicted on the
russian economy i think
again even just last week while he was
in europe the president announced
another round of sanctions in
consultation with our our allies and
partners
so we continue to increase
the pressure and to ensure that we are
inflicting maximum cost uh on russia for
its aggression
what will president biden's response if
israel bombs iran's nuclear reactor
i am not going to get into that kind of
that kind of hypothetical but thank you
thank you for the question
hi um so there are reports that the
administration is considering providing
ukraine with an additional 500 million
in aid and um it's pushing european
countries to make um
the same sort of effort can you confirm
or provide and provide more details on
that so what i can say to that is we are
in constant consultation with our allies
and partners about continued aid to
ukraine uh but discussion of a specific
dollar amount uh there's no discussion
currently of a specific dollar amount
thanks
singapore's first question is uh
the prime minister welcomed
the indo-pacific
uh economic framework we will see when
will we see the exact plan and well the
framework needs to be rectified by the
congress
uh so i don't have an update on a
timeline for you on that um i would
will be happy to come back to you
with further information but i don't
have an update on when you can expect to
see a timeline for that i can
certainly say
that today's meeting between the two
leaders demonstrated the strong security
economic and people-to-people ties
shared by the united states and
singapore and president biden looks
forward to continuing to deepen those
ties and also in the joint statement
the us and singapore reaffirmed the
right of freedom of navigation accorded
by international laws including enclosed
uh will the u.s rectify unclosed
uh under uh by the administration
i don't have an answer for you at this
moment but i'm happy to get more
information and come back to you on it
thank you every couple quick ones
have a couple quick ones for you before
we go uh following up on what torini
asked you with regards to the refugee
programs it can take years for refugees
to be able to be vetted to come into the
united states so does the white house
have a sense of how quickly the
ukrainian refugees will be able to come
to the us
we're working to move as quickly as
possible i don't have a firm timeline
that i can give you but obviously we'll
move as quickly as possible to bring in
as many up to that hundred thousand as
we possibly can and after after florida
governor ron desantis yesterday signed
the state's parental rights and
education legislation education
secretary miguel cardona said the
administration would be monitoring
monitoring its implementation to
evaluate whether it violates federal
civil rights law aside from monitoring
the florida law is there any other
actions that the white house plans to
take
uh well both the president and secretary
cardona spoke out very forcefully
against the law the president also uh
put out a statement yesterday about the
tragic impact of this kind of law an
incredibly vulnerable
population and he said that you know by
signing this bill the governor has
chosen to target some of florida's most
vulnerable students and families all
while under the guise of parents rights
so the department of education as you
noted will continue we'll monitor this
law upon implementation
to evaluate whether it violates federal
civil rights law and obviously we will
uh come back to you as we have more
information on that thank you all very
much appreciate it president trump is
having america rallies in which he
decries the buying
to
administration
you